a lot of the radical left actually if
you look at their behaviors and what
they say they believe in that is
absolutely unprocessed trauma a lot of
that is borderline personality disorder
you can get stuck in Anger you can get
stuck in resentment and stock in pain
and you become
aggressive but you don't mean to I've
lived it I've lived there I know what
being a fringe lunatic radical leftist
says I've literally been there somebody
who's traumatized somebody who's
experienced their sexual and physical
abuse as a kid who's angry with
someone out there who's more powerful
than I am and then you become the
conspiracy theorist it's the structure
it's the patriarchy it's I used to write
essays railing against
um uh Western mechanistic uh scientific
perspectives and I hate I really hated
it because I thought
that's what hurt me I thought that's
what had caused me pain and was causing
pain all around the world does this
weird conspiracy out I'm victimized and
it's like why who who's whose point
who's doing this to you obviously
sometimes that does happen but it's an
obsessive insistence on victimization
through a grand scale conspiracy which
couldn't possibly exist at the scale
that they say it does but it absolves
you of responsibility and that's the
point
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People a brilliant and
returning guest today is one of our
absolute favorites uh he is a man who's
done many many things and he's got a
book out which is called a cult of one
how to de-program yourself from
narcissistic abuse which is an error
specialty Richard grannan welcome back
to trigonometry thanks very much for
having me backed up uh it's really you
look like you've frozen into the chair
yes we'll talk about the book and we'll
talk about all this great stuff made but
we haven't seen you for a while how's
life how have you been uh good busy just
busy with work and um trying to sort
things out and move forward
um I'm having a few problems with with
YouTube at the moment uh starting to
look suspiciously like uh being Shadow
banned so I'm gonna sort that out
tell us um you could make a lot of money
if you can do that yeah well yeah
because a lot of people have the same
suspicion I think I had I had the the a
guy who works for me in conversation
with him yesterday and and they said oh
we've reviewed it and there's absolutely
nothing wrong with your channel even
despite the evidence we gave them and I
just have to move to a new channel so
totally yeah we're gonna have to start a
new channel and I won't put my name in
the videos so I'll go to my email list
and push people through from the list to
the videos because it's a poison
challenge now and there's there's just
that's it like it's interesting because
our numbers have been weird on YouTube
as well because when we do a good
interview with a big name guest it will
do well not as well as it used to
necessarily but it'll do well but if
someone is less known or maybe the
interview is less spicy the numbers are
much lower than they were even though
the channel is bigger and on the podcast
on the audio side of things the numbers
are going up every month you've got on
YouTube because you're never recommended
to me I'm a subscriber of yours I have
to actively go and look for you you're
not uh there's different people are in
Douglas Murray I've watched Douglas
Murray videos all the time and YouTube
never goes oh this guy watches don't
let's give him some Douglas Murray today
never ever happens you guys never come
up with my recommended I have to go and
find you so these are indications that
shadow banned or throttled or whatever
people want to call it like there is a
bit of [ __ ] what's it called a
visibility filtering right yeah
you have been filtered you've been
filtered mate so so there is there is a
bit of there's there's that sort of
aspect of things going on and I'm
thinking okay what's what's the
appropriate way to deal with that what's
the appropriate action for that and uh
you know it's gonna match The Branding
and the effort with the project that I'm
trying to make and all the rest of it so
yeah that's that's going to be the big
one for next year wow man so the book
why did you write it Richard uh I wanted
to get down on paper
and my experiences that led me to doing
the channel as I've been doing up until
now and
I wanted to also sort of convey the
philosophy behind what I teach and have
it all in one place have it you know
fairly easy to read fairly easy to
understand and so I could just say to
people okay if you've got a question for
me you can find it there in the book
so I submitted an 80 000 word academic
style document to the publisher uh the
these gentle Americans and um they sort
of said to me oh this is really
fascinating
um we think it's a little dense and I'm
like it's boring isn't it no no it's not
boring it's just so they they then had
to re-educate me on how to write a book
so they wanted me to do
half every chapter needs to be half an
expose of my own life anecdotes for my
own life and then you earn the right to
teach people something and I was like
you know I went to a British boarding
school I didn't possibly share my
private life so I had to go through this
process of open ing up uh and telling
stories from my own life in the book
which was in the end it was fun once I
learned how to do it and what was that
process like and did you learn something
about yourself while she were doing it
oh gosh yeah I learned
I I it was it became this it became a
therapeutic process it was uh
it took at points it was like pulling
teeth it was really hard it was really
really hard and and the the editors kept
asking me for more they were like we
need more from you we need you to reveal
more about yourself and I was like oh
God I'm really resistant to this there's
parts of me that I do not want in the
public space which like what yeah tell
us now what you didn't want to say so
that was it was but because if you look
like uh on the other side of the coin
it meant it made me think oh wow I'm
really not in alignment with the way our
culture is going because people are
rushing to share their private life they
can't wait to let you know what they had
for breakfast or who they're sleeping
with or what color socks they've got on
they'd love to be seen I hate it I
absolutely just it uh emotifies me I
find it like a really mortifying bro so
I'll show you it was tough but that's
quite interesting because you are a
public person you know you're a
performer you're someone who likes to be
in front of camera you've got a lot of
somebody who likes attention so that's
quite strange isn't it because normally
people are like that want to reveal all
parts of themselves don't they it very
much was a deliberate Persona that was
that was created so I've kept my
protection my psychological
self-protection was always have a public
Persona and then my private life kept
very very separate and it's made uh it I
think it's made my life easier so you
get you see people like they get their
Twitter accounts banned or
and they become very very emotional
they're extremely emotionally attached
to their social media and I'd always
look at that and think I couldn't
possibly I couldn't feel that way and
now I'm realizing it's because they've
put themselves in there and it's parts
of themselves that are getting thrown
away for me it was strictly business
well let's talk about the book because I
I think it you know we we've spoken with
you in the past and there's so much more
to uh you know often we go for dinner
and talk and and there's so much more
that you talk about the narcissism which
is what people will be familiar with you
but we'll start with the narcissism and
um
I suppose in order to recover from
narcissistic abuse you first need to
know that you've experienced it yes you
need to have you need to have a model of
reality that says there is a personality
disorder called narcissism and this is
what they do not just to me but it's
happened to other people multiple times
and it's going on right now so how do
you know that you've been in a
narcissistically abusive relationship uh
when you find yourself at three o'clock
in the morning on YouTube going why is
my girlfriend such a horrible [ __ ] and
I'm looking at videos where my face
comes up and other people's faces and
the field come up there's usually a
sense of confusion about what's going on
in the relationship
and then people well literally they will
put in like why is my husband so cruel
why is my wife is my wife a sadist or
these are the questions that come up in
the Google Search terms and then they
filter through to this this area of
YouTube which is just a ton of this
like so many hours of videos now people
talking about narcissistic abuse there
needs to be a sense that something is
wrong
and it's not just
you know oh she has anger management
issues or oh he's going through a
difficult phase of his life there's a
consistent pattern of bewildering
Behavior here you're stuck in these dead
end conversations that leave you feeling
um
it's called cognitive dissonance it's a
stressful feeling because you're being
asked to believe several different
things that contradict each other at the
same time and it creates a feeling of
stress somatically in the body some
people are generalized they can't sleep
they get physical symptoms and they
start obsessively hunting for answers so
that obsessive Hunt For answers is the
first indicator that somebody is
probably in a emotionally abusive
relationship at least and what do we
mean by emotionally abusive because the
problem is Richard is it like a lot of
words now at one point they meant one
thing and now they mean you know
something completely different well a
woman was asked where she's really from
and that was called the trauma and
sustained right they sustained abuse and
and whatever yeah did you follow this
yes uh a woman was asking Fulani and she
was dressed in full African regime yeah
yeah and an old white lady said to her
oh and where are you from yeah because
you're clearly representing a country
yeah and that was soon as the most
aggressive form of attack well well she
said it was traumatic so this I guess
France's point is like you know you
might have just had an argument with
your partner yeah that's not the same as
being narcissistically abused no you're
you're pointing to an effect that was
identified by a scholar from Brent Brent
or Ghent University Ghent university
called Yan DeVos it's called
psychologization and he pointed out the
first paper in 2012. it's the effect by
which psychology itself has seeped out
into the culture and
pathologized so there's pathologization
where we think everything is a medical
issue and then beyond that is
psychologization the things that are not
psychological issues are being rendered
psychological issues so yes emotional
abuse had one meaning
um you were with a partner who's abusive
but they didn't hit you they used
coercive control and now if I say I
don't like the color of your socks that
could be considered emotional abuse it
depends on where the dial on sensitivity
is scaled up to yes that's a part of the
conversation that we can't have in a
psychologized society because
psychology won't go there psychology is
in its you know effectively a very
left-leaning field and you can't
question the victim because that would
be called we have a term for that as
well
and that is the sin that's a sin against
the Orthodoxy that we live under now so
you can't you basically can't say
something is traumatic and something is
abusive but some things aren't because
as long as someone claims of those
things are traumatic and abusive you
would be denying their pain and blaming
them I think the language they use is
you're denying their lived experience
yeah yeah
um and so
that actually wasn't the normal stance
of psychology for a long time if you go
back men and women male and female
psychologists for years would push back
against that because they would say well
you're not mentally well you need
objective feedback to know where you're
up to somewhere
you know radical maybe radical feminism
promoted it maybe radical feminists got
into more of the faculties more of the
social sciences post-modernism crap 10
Marxism crap 10
um and yes it became a case of saying no
the subjective experience is all
important but only the subjective
experience of certain select individuals
and we're not going to tell you who
you're going to find out when you're
being punished
so it's a maddening of this maddening
situation I I still love psychology but
it is a mess it's an absolute mess but
the thing that's bizarre about that is
in many ways when you do that you're not
helping people no that's what you're
making from zika I mean it's provable
it's a
uh what's his name Jonathan height wrote
a bow set and the coddling of the
American mind he used Jan devos's
psychologization and connected it to a
concept created by two Australian
psychologists called looping so if you
say to somebody
um you're the victim here and you're
sick by a process of looping they'll
identify with that version of themselves
and they'll create more victimization
for themselves and they'll see
themselves as vulnerable
Jonathan Heights uh point now as I look
at the generation of kids now they see
themselves as completely vulnerable
because of this psychologization and
it's not I don't think psychology
intrinsically should lead this lean this
way you can have a version of psychology
that is much more philosophically robust
than you teach people no we the
psychologist expects you to be strong
your counselor expects you to be strong
we don't just
I call it tea and biscuits like tea and
biscuit psychology is crap psychology
ah poor you would you like a biscuit
that's not gonna help it's not because
we have to get down to look you're an
adult do you want to function in this
reality this is what you need to do the
responsibility must be spread it can't
be offset because that creates an
externalized locus of control which is
known to be highly associated with
anxiety and depression because you feel
like you're not in control of your life
right and this is why I feel the timing
of your book so great I haven't had a
chance to read it yet but I will look
forward to doing it over Christmas
because I think the timing is right and
you know how sometimes people come along
um and they definitely have a really
good set of things to share with the
world but the timing is not right and it
doesn't work out whereas whenever I
think about something like Jordan
Peterson for example I think there's a
reason that he exploded in the way that
he did yeah because the message was
necessary and I feel the way you
approach this issue it's kind of how I
always thought about life as well is
like you could spend your life being a
victim and if I listed all the things
that I've I've been homeless my family's
been destined like I can be gone for
ages but it's not going to improve my
life right no and I think that's kind of
the message that you're bringing as well
which is here's a set of steps to
actually overcome things that you've
been through right 100 and I was
thinking of Jordan Peterson uh he had
this mildly amusing joke when he
addressed the Oxford Union and he said
there's there's very very few
right-leaning psychologists in the world
in fact the only one of them is here in
the room with you now which
is is not least because he's actually on
the left but we've had this conversation
before like as as far as the today's
left is concerned he's literally Hitler
so
um but he is that it was that flavor of
that type of psychologist still
psychology but it still has its roots in
nature and Dostoyevsky which was you
know yeah you're you're on your own in
this world and you have to strive and
you have to fight which is a more of a
if you take a yin yang perspective
that's more of a Yang approach that's
more of a
um a masculine principled approach the
feminine principled approach would be no
you need top-down assistance from a
community to help you you need both like
balance and everything but we've gone
too far this way yeah so everything
becomes an appeal to Authority if you're
in pain and you have a boo-boo then you
have to call for Authority at least
authoritarian that's why you throw super
paintings yes to save the climate that's
why you do all this stuff and I actually
I did a debate at the Oxford Union which
they haven't released yet but this is
one of the things I talked about is like
if you think climate change is a really
big problem
um then complaining about it
is literally not going to do anything
right particularly in Britain which
produces two percent of global carbon
emissions even if you disappeared
Britain from the map it still wouldn't
change anything right you've got to
you've got to do something you've got to
create technology you've got to have
inventions you've got to pursue that and
we've somehow as you say ended up in a
position where we just as a culture we
don't that's not the attitude the
attitude is Big Daddy government or this
or that you know the society has failed
me systemic this structural that yes yes
systemic they're structural that which
comes from I said it's Yen principled
which is feminine principle it comes
from feminism it's a it's from feminism
I don't see why his YouTube channel is
not doing as well anymore
you keep that up Mr granted and see
where it gets sure
just turning the dial he's winding about
birds again so so there is that like to
me
um like being I would say the left is
generally Yen principled it's it's
kindness It's fairness the right tends
to be young principled it's
competitiveness and it's it's requires
more resilience it believes in it a
prioritize it I think we need balance in
all these things but
when I say the cult or yandavos said the
culture is psychologized he wasn't
saying it's psychologized with
nietzschean psychology or adlerian
psychology he's saying it's
psychologized with this these are
radical feminists Marx says
post-modernist ideas that do point at
structures that and the interesting
thing is they kind of become conspiracy
theorists there's this weird conspiracy
out I'm victimized and it's like who
who's who's Point who's doing this to
you obviously sometimes that does happen
but it's an obsessive insistence on
victimization through a grand scale
conspiracy which couldn't possibly exist
at the scale that they say it does but
it absolves you of responsibility and
that's the point so that's that's that's
why I think it's gone that way yeah I
was listening to uh Gabor mate I'm
really going do you I don't know if you
know Gabor I love gobble yeah yeah yeah
and he talks a lot about trauma and it
just made me realize that actually what
you see with a lot of people's negative
behavior in my opinion is just their
unprocessed trauma that they've never
really looked into or never wanted to
deal with and then they just go around
just vomiting it yeah which is a lot of
the radical left actually if you look at
their behaviors and what they say they
believe in that is absolutely
unprocessed trauma a lot of that is
borderline personality disorder
you're not supposed to say that even
Jordan Peterson resisted saying it for
the first five years that he shot to
fame he wouldn't I had uh friends and
clients of mine go to a seminars and ask
him and he would refuse to he would
refuse to answer it he's saying it now
that's borderline personality disorder
well the interesting thing about that is
in terms of the point you're making
Francis is it's easy it's much easier to
say because the radical right is exactly
the same I have a uh I I used to be
friends with some people
um anyway in the movie world and there's
a brilliant I think it's Finnish movie
called Heart of a Lion about neo-nazis
and I met a brilliant film about neonats
he's a brilliant film about neo-nazis
I'm a big admirer of yeah promotional
man yeah exactly that's why we started
the show that's where all the merch is
from anyway
the actors did a lot of research yeah
to to get ready to play a neonati and
they said that when they met these
people who'd been reformed neo-nazis or
just were neonatis almost all of them
had a certain childhood experience yes
traumatic childhood experiences shaped
them into seeing the world in that way
and and that makes perfect sense that
like the people who are out there doing
extreme [ __ ] they're probably doing it
for for a reason you know what I mean
100
um
that the chances of well anybody who has
extremist views that can easily be
challenged inside of a 20-minute sober
conversation not having some issues
related to their sanities becomes very
very small so yeah radical anything so
yeah radical right-wingers again you'll
see borderline personality disorder
because they'll be they're extremely
emotionally disregulated damages their
perceptions everything is still an
externalized locus of control you
mentioned the Nazis that was absolutely
a victimhood story right another Jewels
it was all one one group yeah for
everything and you think you know if you
sat down and be like are you sure like
that's it that's your view of reality
you wouldn't even spread their
responsibility out could you name like
five different groups on that nope just
one nine like we say like we say in
Russian if there's no water in the tab
the Jews drank it
that's how people think though right you
know and those people any those those
people it creates an infantile view of
reality and I think a lot of the
problems that we're seeing nowadays is
we're not having adult conversations
because people aren't coming from an
adult point of view they're literally
not capable of having the adult
conversation because they're traumatized
they're stuck in an infantile world view
the emotional dysregulation turns your
perceptions upside down people don't
realize how how sick they've become
and they crave this ideology because it
it moderates the emotions externally so
they they follow I don't know maybe they
become neo-nazis or maybe they become
radical leftists or so or or whatever
and because that makes them feel a
little bit better it stops the screaming
in their head for a few minutes Richard
I'm going to put a Counterpoint to you
isn't it even more oh yeah if you don't
mean make some they're not all bad
someone is going to clip that by the way
um but
it's becoming more and more difficult
Richard to keep your sanity when you
look around at the world and what is
reality is rapidly
let's be fair to come in undone like you
you just see that the media has been
lying to us you saw what happened with
covid you saw that we were told one
thing about vaccines and I'm keeping it
deliberately deliberately opaque because
you know we know what will happen with
YouTube and now the reality is something
else yeah we've been consistently lied
to for a long time yeah so
Can you blind people from distrusting
reality
um
blame that's interesting that's
interesting okay so to push back on that
I would say that we all as adults have a
responsibility to approach well you said
this point I would feed your point back
to you we all have to process our trauma
it's rough right now I agree and the
fact that we're seeing more and more
people emotionally dysregulated
especially after lockdowns and
everything else surprises me not at all
the the thing that bothers me at the
moment
um is it feels like the effort to coerce
people's opinions and to move them in a
certain direction is being increased and
that largely speaking people are going
along with that which is it's it's very
worrying I find I'm
pretty worried about where we're up to
at the moment
when I last spoke to you I was much more
like oh no you said you said we were
heading to gulags and genocide but then
the last time we spoke in the in the
interview that's gone missing yes oh you
interviewed that you were quite positive
we did a great interview man and I hope
we we can record because something went
wrong with the hard drive uh but you did
a great interview with us and I can't
wait for people to see that hopefully we
can get that back man it was really good
yeah
um sorry no but that being the case look
what would you do as an individual
how do you operate in a world where you
look around
and things you're being deliberately
misled
you've been deliberately misinformed
I don't know I don't I don't know what
we need so sometimes I think you know I
question myself when I say are you this
is Richard to Richard are you flirting
with uh an idea an idea of a narrative
that you haven't that you don't dare to
fully realize because it's going to be
extremely inconvenient which at this
point would be I have to become
politically engaged and every fiber in
my being goes oh God not that you
everyone who does that so no no
disrespect but like everyone who does
that make kind of makes a fool of
themselves in the end because it's
loaded with Dogma you say well this is
the policy by which everybody should
live it's always gonna you always end up
look you look stupid on some issues at
some point and then another part he says
well what else is there because you have
to give people directions so if you're
not going to give them Direction
politically
what are you going to do oh we use
psychology psychology is infected and I
think I've spread the infection I'm one
of the people who popularizes the idea
of microaggressions and being
traumatized by words I'm one of those
people
what so what philosophy religion
spirituality I don't know I wouldn't
have the balls
to uh to to go out there and and start
preaching at a philosophical or
spiritual level so I I don't I don't
know what to do I'm at a loss well I I
think look I I keep saying this in every
[ __ ] interview people are probably
gonna get as Fed Up of it as France is
saying he used to be a teacher but
you know becoming a father this year
really gave me part of the answer to
that part of the answer to what we're
talking about is family man yeah and
human connection and family connection
yes uh that answers like 80 to 90 of all
this existential [ __ ] that people
struggle with on a day-to-day basis it's
that man it's it's a lack of meaning
it's a lack of purpose and if you don't
have that it's very hard to be grounded
and attached to whatever it is that you
know having my son has completely
changed my worldview and I went from
being one of these guys who used to hate
parents banging on about it because I'm
now one of them yeah you know I can't
help it but that's because it's added me
I've always been someone who wanted
meaningful work and trigonometry is is
that for me and always has been but
having family uh having children that
because they need you yeah and they are
vulnerable yeah right so I can't afford
to be needy and vulnerable because
there's a small little creature that
needs me right now my wife needs me
right now she needs me to provide she
needs me to be there emotionally and it
forces me to get out of my own head yes
and get into the real world where [ __ ]
needs to be done and I think that's part
of the answer man and I'm afraid you
know people don't like being told this
and I used to hate being told this but I
think it's very very difficult to
for most people there will be of course
be exceptions but for most people I
think without taking that extra step
it's very difficult to be an adult like
I do I look back at me even two years
ago and I think I was a mature young
person
um
that's that's the best that I would call
it I think a big part of the reason we
are where we are is the the plummeting
birth rate the people delaying having
children you know what do you think
about that
I think uh it was predicted by Aleister
Crowley of all people back in 1901 he
wrote a book about this that said we're
going to move into an age of infantilism
he called it the Aeon of Horus
um and then young picked that up never
credited Crowley and called it the uh
which was right for probably the right
thing to do uh he called it the puer
eternus which means the Eternal child so
we now live in the age of the Eternal
child and yes you're probably right
as as biological entities we don't fully
enter our adulthood unless we have
children of Our Own
I don't know if it's a solution to say
to people have kids yeah you're really
[ __ ] up go and have some kids to solve
that yeah I agree and there's also
there's going to be
because everything is politicized as
well as psychologized now it sounds
right wing well having kids yeah
well isn't that [ __ ] up though that's
insane isn't it it's completely insane
but you see but everything's right when
the guardian put did an article about
what going to the gym is right wing yeah
absolutely it is
a funny way of like the thing is what
what all this all that's doing is is
it's if if
being healthy physically yes if being
healthy mentally yes if having a family
and children if taking responsibility if
not asking for handouts from the
government if not asking for the big
systemic oppression to be overturned if
if all of that is right wing they're
sort of pushing all healthy people to
the right well there's
um
there's another uh Dot and Professor
dotton the Jolly Aerotek who reviews The
evolutionary psychology research and he
says that I believe him there's evidence
to suggest that on the whole right wing
people are healthier and better looking
they have better DNA better genetics
right we need to move to the right yeah
exactly we need to stop pretending to be
in the center we have we've become far
right in the course of this conversation
and and you look you look at that and
you think oh God I hope that's not true
but I don't I don't know what I don't
know what the right means so what does
it mean nowadays if you're on the right
so are we saying that one is
life-affirming and individualistic uh
where the other one is kind of life
negating and globalist maybe maybe
that's the division maybe that's what we
should be talking about on this side
here humans are bad we're a burden on
the earth we're a burden on the
environment we're overpopulated
masculinity is bad uh femininity is bad
sexuality is bad all of all of that it's
like a death cult and on the other side
you have people who are life affirming
and they want to have children and they
want to
move forward and have a sense of Pride
and a sense of dignity in their own
lives
and there's that we got right and left
wing from the French Revolution are we
still having the same conversation I
mean it seems like we're probably not so
we're using these terms I I disagree
with people who say the terms are now
meaningless but we have to see how far
warped the world has has gone this isn't
about so in the French Revolution it was
either you you wanted to keep the
royalty and you want to keep the church
you wanted to preserve things the way
they were or you wanted to turn
everything on its head so left wing is a
revolutionaries right Wingers keep
everything the same way this is this is
a little different and I think there's
different agendas that got tagged on and
because they could be so people who were
of the left based on that point in human
history were open to ideas like
globalization open to ideas like
population reduction in environmentalism
the notion that we are an evil virus on
the world and the world would be better
if there were just less of us or none of
us here at all which seems to be like
the Pinnacle of modern left-wing
ideology the most righteous person would
be all humans are trash just get rid of
the whole lot of us that's my humble
opinion that's if you follow the the
dictates that seems to be where it goes
to so yes the life-affirming people
probably will be healthier and you know
have less genetic mutation be slightly
more intelligent and so on
hey Francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium-like TV
then simply sit back and watch all your
hard-earned money disappear down the
toilet what about advertising with
trigonometry why would I do that when I
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets 2 million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your advert will be written by
two professional comedians yeah that's
right we're hiring two professional
comedians
when we make our ads funny and engaging
to the point where some people say the
ads are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing
triggerpod.co.uk that's marketing a
triggerpod DOT Co dot UK advertise with
us and we'll get your business canceled
for me covered through all of this into
really sharp relief because
I saw two groups of people in when it
when covid happened there were the
people who were just like well the
government knew the government needs to
support me the government needs to bail
me out the guy I need furlough blah blah
blah yeah and those people who were like
well
I've just got to get on with it and of
course there's more Nuance to that there
were there unfortunately there were some
businesses that could no longer operate
because of because of covid and a lot of
people couldn't do their job that's why
they needed to follow yeah the
government forced them not to exactly
but but there was the attitude of of
particularly my industry with with
comedy in our industry at the time where
comedians were were saying well I need
to be bailed out and it's like well I
understand that your industry has
stopped but that doesn't mean that you
can't navigate other areas yes you can't
do other things you're denying your
agency yes yeah the I we may have
discussed this before but I've always
been on adopted the left the left-wing
uh largely left-wing uh argument and
psychology which is that most things in
life are due to trauma the environment
and nurture but with covid I really
started to see a reaction that I thought
was nature based because it was so fast
and people were so certain of their
position literally within weeks without
questioning it and I started to see that
split you said that you were presenting
a non-nuanced version of reality but I
would say the response was non-nuanced
like it was really low resolution every
largely speaking people went one of two
ways they either wanted blind submission
to Authority and bailouts or they wanted
to fight against Authority and sort
themselves out so you just had
authoritarianism versus uh essentially
individualism and I that was so fast and
so I never had any doubts I wasn't like
oh but I do like a bit of
authoritarianism I was like [ __ ] no ah
get that away from me absolutely not but
people really close to me went all the
way the other way overnight and I
thought for the first time ever in my
life I thought maybe there is a genetic
component to this this could be rooted
in our biology because there was some
people who just craved it yeah yeah and
they saw the government expansion of
governmental control in their lives as a
positive and they loved it and they
loved it and and they craved it and they
wanted more yeah 100 it makes sense I
mean one of our favorite fellow favorite
guests is a guy called Stephen Hicks
who's a philosopher and his historian I
feel like I don't know if you're
familiar with him yeah I've listened to
him I'm a big fan of him and this is one
of the points that he made is people who
are temperamentally fearful of the
future of life of the world they don't
feel uh competent or able to solve their
own problems it is very natural to those
people to then cling towards
authoritarianism because
in a time of panic in a time of fear if
you don't feel able to solve the problem
or someone else has got to solve the
problem right and who's that going to be
the government and if other people are
refusing to cooperate
yeah what do you do well let's get the
hammer out you know it it it to me I I
kind of I had compassion for the desire
to rely on governmental forces and and
to have that appeal to Authority a
top-down appeal to Authority but it was
so unquestioning it made me laugh I
thought people were joking I was like
why would you trust your government to
do that what evidence do you have that
your government is qualified for this
and they go well it's the government
just do what they say I'm like look at
it falling over each other like clowns
in a circus that that's who we're
trusting and then they just just
there was this stressful response like
just do as you say do as they say and
everything will be okay do as they say
and everything will be okay stop asking
questions it threatens our survival it
was like we were on a life raft and I
was standing up waving my arms they're
like you're gonna capsize us all and I
was like I don't see that the world is
like this I don't see it the way you
guys are saying it at all but they
absolutely saw it that way it was it was
an amazing I'm still not fully recovered
if I'm if I'm being really honest I kind
of I trust people a lot less I trust
institutions far less now and well the
times we're living through now every
month that goes by you see more and more
reason to be uh um deeply suspicious of
what any of our institutions are saying
which institutions can we trust you
don't trust your church you don't trust
your media you don't trust your
government you don't trust the police
who can you trust
if we really lose all trust for all of
our institutions our civilization's
moving nowhere yeah and that's something
that I think people don't realize when
they
you know they talk in such hyperbolic
manner manners and you know they try to
put forward this narrative about Civil
War and you know talking about the West
collapsing and these grandiose terms you
just go
you're not doing good here yeah yeah
yeah you know there's a way to discuss
these things and these things do need to
be discussed but there's also a sensible
way to discuss them without being
inflammatory and without trying to
polarize people
yes I I think the the leaning towards
being uh inflammatory and polarizing it
it's an unfortunate side effect of the
in the brain entrainment that social
media has given us you just get more
likes you just get more views that way
yeah the more of a deck you are the more
ridiculous statements you make
um the three people who are sat here now
would have more Instagram followers if
we deliberately wound people up every
week and just adopted the more polarized
view on any topic just take the most
polarized View and just Hammer that view
on any topic this is what I was going to
ask you you talk about not being fully
recovered and I think as a society we
really haven't fully recovered because
uh one of the things that there's
obviously a thing that exists which is
uh what on on Twitter people call I
support the current thing right which is
the government and the mainstream media
are saying You must do this therefore
you must do this yes yeah we've now also
seen that there is that I oppose the
current thing okay and there's a whole
economy of of people who are doing what
you're saying which is going oh the
government is saying this what would be
the very up oh here we go yeah you know
and then before you know it you know
like and whatever whatever the opposite
is of what the government is saying it's
always there and and people who
literally have and I've I saw it with
the war in Ukraine yeah because it's
something that I know a lot about by
virtual background having family
connections speaking a language blah
blah and I suddenly saw these people
people I know yeah people who couldn't
find Ukraine on a map right having very
strongly held very very extreme opinions
about that subject and I think you've
explained it perfectly and guess what I
reckon
if Donald Trump had won the last
election
and he was the one sending money to
Ukraine yeah it would be exactly flipped
all the people who now oppose it would
support it and all the people who
currently support it would oppose it I
mean not all obviously but the majority
yes and I I agree with you and I think
that that says something very sad about
the state of modern politics yeah so
when I was in California and I was I was
talking to people there uh I was I was
there in October and I was saying you
know I was asking around like do you
would you vote for Biden again and they
said yeah absolutely we would vote for
buying again what with no reservation
whatsoever and the attitude that I got
and the answer I got from most people
was I would vote for anybody as long as
it meant that Trump didn't get back in I
was like okay just
yeah but listen to yourself speak that's
your your vote is just to stop someone
you don't like from getting in
that's not democracy that I I don't know
what you call that but that can't be
that's not what the voting system is
designed to do I'll just hate my enemies
at any cost it's not
it's not I want this I believe in this
policy this education policy is good
it's just screw the other guys whatever
it takes to beat them that's what we're
gonna do that is not a healthy uh State
football is extra bit no because it's
just built on Revenge 100
and what you see in our culture a lot of
what is going on is Revenge yeah one
side does one thing to another side
which is unfair and wrong and then the
other side then does the same thing
and then they start using each other's
weapons like the left started out
canceling people and then the right went
actually you know what we're gonna do
the same thing yes
yes and you and you go well okay but
what's the end game for that
yeah it creates an awful lot of
resentment more emotional dysregulation
perceptions become more skewed
um I don't I again when I look at this I
think what is the solution I liked
before what you said about family family
community uh there is a practical
solution I could get behind a movement
that said let's bring people back
together face to face it's England what
was the United cold it's a bit of a pain
in the ass but we probably should see
more of each other because we're all in
our houses seeing each other through
this evil thing that just generates the
jungian shadow in you uh you get a very
strange view of people there's not that
many extremists actually out there no
they don't live on your road they don't
go to your local if you knew the people
around you you'd probably feel that
we're better plus I suspect that it's
just a good evolutionary match we
probably just should be sat around
looking at each other we should be sat
around the campfire at the end of the
day just looking at each other and
talking and that would probably bring a
lot of the stress levels down I suspect
so and I think as well man like whenever
we talk about Solutions we've all we've
all become very uh extreme left about it
in the we always think we need a
movement and a system and a whatever
whereas actually I think the truth is a
lot of the solution to what you know
people go through life and most people
live lives where they experience a lot
of anxiety a lot of fear about the
future a lot of loneliness a lot of
disconnection the answer to that is not
for the three of us to sit here and
devise a system yeah it's for you as an
individual for me as an individual to go
for a walk to go to the gym to have
children and look after them to to make
sure your relationship is open to get
therapy if that's what you need because
sometimes that's what you need too right
to to put things in place in your own
life that make your life better and then
when we come on set here we can have a a
conversation as people who are
emotionally better regulated than
otherwise would be I think that's much
more the answer than coming up with a
grand plan I actually didn't realize
that I was unconsciously doing that but
you're right
of a left-wing sort of unconscious
left-wing responses like there should be
a movement why
that's an externalized locus of control
and all that all that that would do is
further infantilize people but I think
I've been trained into that because a
lot of my interactions with people are
through social media and they're
constantly saying to me do something I'm
like oh I maybe I have to do something
but you're right no I don't why why the
[ __ ] should I do you do something you're
an adult I like I'm an adult what do I
know well as people who talk in public
are in public or do things in public I
think that's actually quite a big part
of it is just and I and I I'm not using
myself as an example I remember
15 years ago I I saw a clip of Peter
Hitchens who I used to think was a
right-wing lunatic until I became a
Centrist lunatic or whatever I am now
and he was talking about cyclization of
everything right and he said you know a
lot of people a lot of time people now
talk about things where the solution is
just to go for a brisk walk yeah and I
realized I was sitting at home having
spent the entire day in front of my
computer first working then playing
computer games right feeling [ __ ] yeah
and here I was on YouTube listening to
Peter Hitchens yeah why not go for a
walk and I went for a walk and I felt
better amazing and I was like oh yeah
that's the answer yeah and this is I
think because
we've got to a point where we think that
thought is power yeah and it's not
thought plus action is power yes action
is power right but thought you can't
think your way out of a paper bag you
have to do things yes right and I think
this is where I'm really interested to
hear what you talk about in the book in
terms of the Practical steps for people
to overcome what they've experienced in
that kind of relationship so tell us
more about the Practical steps of
dealing with things like that there's a
few things that I advocate for in the
book one of them
as an exercise I came up with for myself
when I was two years ago back in 2013 I
was living in Kuala Lumpur I wasn't
mentally particularly doing very well
and uh I formulated this exercise where
I wanted to get an objective sense of
where I was in the world and how people
saw me so I did like a profit and loss
account put a line right down the middle
how do I see myself what am I really
about and then I listed how do other
people see me
the disparity between the two like I had
no control
or that I had a very
big gap between what my intention was
and how I was allowing other people to
see me
you know I was
a 100 kilogram fat white guy with a
shaved head living in a largely Chinese
conservative area
and people would treat me with suspicion
and they looked at me like a criminal
because they were racist
because I can't be racist to white
people they would have been racist if I
wasn't Gammon they would be racist
but they looked at me like I was a
criminal because I kind of looked like a
criminal I was in a place where there
was there was nobody else there like me
I didn't
dress very well I didn't care about my
parents when I spoke to people I used a
very abrasive style of humor that I
thought was funny but it was often a lot
of like sexual jokes or violent jokes or
things that are kind of a little bit
shocking
and I sort of looked at that and was
like okay I don't want people to see me
that way there's a lot of stuff I'm
saying and doing here that is giving
people a sense of who I am that's a
million miles away from what I care
about what my values are
and getting a hold of that
really made a huge difference in my life
because if you're internally this but
you're you're externally projecting that
the feedback you're getting from the
social environment is not congruent with
who you are and you end up with this
weird sense of alienation from yourself
that creates a huge amount of depression
and anxiety those people that we've been
talking about today like extremists on
both sides of the polarization
politically who I think you know with
like a one or two day seminar you could
do work with them like let's just be
like okay you're you're very angry about
something what are you trying to tell
people well okay they're just calmly
just can we write it down and then feed
it back to them socratically are you
saying until they're satisfied that
you've got to sense of what they're
trying to say and then just explore the
possibility that maybe there's a way of
conveying it that doesn't require all
this
you can get stuck in Anger you can get
stuck in resentments and stock in pain
and you become aggressive but you don't
mean to I've lived it I've lived it I
know what being I know what being a
fringe lunatic radical leftist says I've
literally been there somebody's
traumatized somebody who's experienced
their sexual and physical abuse as a kid
who's angry with
someone out there who's more powerful
than I am and then you become the
conspiracy theorist it's the structure
it's the patriarchy it's I used to write
essays railing against
um uh Western mechanistic uh scientific
perspectives and I hate I I really hated
it because I thought
that's what had hurt me I thought that's
what had caused me pain and was causing
pain all around the world
and you can if you're stuck there you
can build that narrative like if we did
a writing exercise all three of us could
write like that it's not
it's not impossible to get into that
headspace but then slowly over time you
just have to look and say okay is that
true you know is the history of the
United Kingdom one of colonization
genocide and slavery and nothing else
for example this is one of those it's uh
I remember listening to Douglas Murray
break that down and when I'm trying to
get into that headspace that's the
example I go to first I'm like okay
where are the contravating examples
where do you see the bits and pieces
that move against that very simplistic
and kind of satiating narrative it's
like eating a big fat burger because it
it gives you everything you want
straight away yes England is all for
United Kingdom is awful white people are
awful it's all slowed down there's a few
facts historically speaking that we have
to look at oh that's hard I have to
think yeah you might you might have to
think you might have to look at some
things that won't make you comfortable
that that will go against this uh I
think some of these narratives they're
placatory it's like it's sucking your
thumb you're basically sucking your
thumb and going okay I feel better now
Richard do you think as well let's go
back to narcissism to me the conspiracy
theories and conspiracy theorists and
narcissism they're quite they seem to be
linked because it's someone going
I've got the answers yes I really know
what's going on yeah and you see them
all the time on social media going this
thing that's just happened this major
world event this happened because of
it's about me yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know yeah and inside and I know why
this has happened and it's because of
this and it's like well no you don't and
isn't that quite a grandiose thing to
say that you were one of the few people
who actually really understands yes I am
a member of the Gnostic Brotherhood of
the Illuminati and I know the truth yeah
yeah it's very grandiose and
yes it's fueled by I think I think it's
called ideas of reference which is a
self-centered you're basically saying
this is all about me fundamentally The
Narrative that they have behind
everything they're saying is all roads
lead back to Rome which is me I am Rome
this is all about me
um and yes there is there is a
narcissism to that as well because it's
not only is it grandiose
it's riddled with ideas ideas of
reference self-reference
but it's delusional like you just said
like no you don't know none of us really
know we can look at the evidence and we
can hypothesize and we can challenge uh
whatever the the major narrative is but
not nobody actually really knows and
where did you get your effing certainty
from and does that serve you to be that
certain all the time about every single
topic
it doesn't make sense it's not
I I think that is uh that's a
philosophical Point that's where I would
say okay here I can see a gap in the
puzzle and that definitely philosophy
goes in there let's learn to think again
let's make thinking great again you know
the Socratic method let's go back and
forth what what is your position as
there any evidence you've ever seen that
contravenes that opposes that position
okay well you know let's think in a more
nuanced way let's learn to think whereas
what we have now is a screaming mob and
that obviously reduces all everything
becomes low resolution there's low
resolution perspectives of problems and
they yield low resolution Solutions of
course they do that are highly emotive
and
extremely self-serving so yes absolutely
there is an artist isn't there and it's
also as well you know this is the thing
that I find depressing is that if
someone says one thing normally you can
see like oh you're gonna you're gonna
think this so for instance if someone's
really distrustful of the government and
they think the government is corrupt and
they're not being honest which is a
legitimate point of view yeah you kind
of go yeah I bet you're into Bitcoin
so these Rebels actually become just
carbon copy Printing and then it's the
same on the other side as well and they
all think the same way about a specific
set of things and then it's like you're
saying we need to actually make thinking
great Again by going well you can think
the government is corrupt and they
probably are yeah but that doesn't mean
that Bitcoin is going to be the solution
that's really interesting I never
thought of it that way before actually
yes you can see if this person adopts
wow you could probably create a graph or
something for this well there will be
and there will be like I mean the
correlation between people in America
who are anti-abortion and pro-gun or or
Pro masks and therefore Pro tax Rises
you know like I mean one thing just
trips well it's like fish and chips you
can't have one without the other for
some reason you know what I mean so your
super pro mask but you're also super
pro-abortion well there would be yeah oh
sorry Pro Health except for before right
right yeah no I suppose I so I suppose
it makes sense because there's a
congruence of values there but I also I
also think what you're saying is
interesting it's like we just fall into
an archetype yeah because I believe this
well I don't have to think then do I I
could just ingest I could just imagine
my mind because look Joe Rogan for
example we talked to him about this
she's massively into guns I think he's
massively pro-choice as far as I
understand I don't know if he's
massively approached it was definitely
you know not everyone has to align with
the leashes that's why I call myself a
Centrist it's not because I am in the
center of every issue yeah as we've
established on some issues I'm far right
but but you know what I mean like
there's certain things about which I
feel quite strongly to one side there's
issues about which I feel strongly to
the left you know decriminalization of
certain drugs for example you know
um and then you this interest isn't
really a good way of describing that I'm
just someone who wants to think about
things on an individual basis as opposed
to get a package off the shelf yes and I
do Wonder like when it comes to Joe
Rogan
if there's obviously a lot of reasons
for his appeal but I think that could be
one of them that could be one of them is
that the guy can be pro-hunting Pro meat
eating pro-gun and then very pro-choice
and in America that's it's a pretty it's
a pretty rare thing I meet people like
that if I want to meet people like that
when I go and visit my sister in
California there's a place called iron
sights there's a shooting range it's
like a 40 minute drive from our house
and that's where you'll meet that
yeah you can't put them in boxes because
they they're Californians they vote this
way but they love their cons and they
will disappear off into the woods if
they feel if they feel they need to they
can survive
um so there is there is that there so
there's there is a degree of of nuance
there and with him I also think
the encouragement to thought but not in
like
where he doesn't have a snotty English
accent and he doesn't come from a
highbrow
perspective quoting different various
authors that you're never going to read
because they're hard to read it's more
of that sort of like a guy who took
psychedelics and he's like did you ever
think that maybe and just like um that's
philosophy actually that's kind of a
philosophical exercise it's a Socratic
exercise which I think I think that
leads to the uh the the the broadness of
his appeal it's also as well I think you
know
but thinking for yourself and
challenging narratives and developing
your own points of view is going to
ostracize you from certain people yeah
it just is yeah and I think people are
really scared of that Richard because
we're fundamentally tribal we we want to
be around people we want to be accepted
I mean you get the odd person who's I
don't care and they're fine with it but
I think the majority of us just want our
tribe
yeah you crave it yeah yeah definitely
so there is a there's a biological
Instinct towards
um conforming and I think
I think that's one of the things that is
hard to identify in a moment of
polarization because you say well
polarization is a real problem but it's
the conformist element to it that kind
of frightens me and it depresses me if
I'm being really honest I find it quite
depressing to see how quickly people
will throw themselves into Conformity
with the party line whatever it is we're
all going to believe this
and I'm going to be very predictable on
all my answers to everything without
thought
that just that's not philosophy that's
ideology something is thinking for you
it's like you've got a brain parasite
that's just just doing the thinking for
you
um I find that depressing I think
because of how willingly people have
given up their
their sovereignty in that sense like
it's just too hard to think that well
maybe it's something like this the
world's become too complicated I can't
think so think for me and I'll just
chant whatever you tell me it's a chance
just absolves me of the need to think it
through for myself and it has become
very complicated hasn't it yeah I mean
if you think about almost any issue I
mean climate change is a good example of
this and I I don't imagine among your
many talents you're a climate scientist
neither of us is so when you're
presented with
um
a certain worldview about that issue and
you are it's not just a world you you
are told that there are certain things
that must be done as a result yes
and then on top of that you go well I I
don't know what's going on I'm not an
expert in this area I'm told that we
have to do these pretty drastic things
and if I don't want to do them or if I
don't necessarily believe this or if I
have questions about this or if whatever
then I'm a bad person yeah
and in that situation I think for a lot
of people the Temptation is to just go
well this is what we're being told then
that's what we must do
um which look and this is kind of the
point is there's a hundred other issues
like that you know we've got strikes in
this country are they good thing or a
bad thing
I don't know do you does anyone yeah you
know you you can have a view on it but
do you know no and you know is
technology good or bad the way that it's
changing at the moment it's got lots of
positives it's got lots of down do you
give your kid a mobile phone you know
what all of these questions are really
really complicated
um and you I think that a lot of the
stuff that we talk about on the show a
lot of the stuff that people who watch
our show are dealing with is the fact as
you say the world is getting very
complicated very quickly and maybe then
maybe then there is a need to to learn
to think uh that becomes quite urgent
because we can ask questions Upstream of
the questions you've just asked which
would be what is good what is bad like
if you say strikes are bad what's the
bad but why I'm when we say it's good
why is something good you probably do
need that because the larger a more
existential and more complex the problem
is the more likely it is to induce
submission in the person who's facing it
uh the climate change one yeah I find I
find mind
I'm presented with data and I'm told
it's absolutely necessary that we must
do these things off the back of that
data and I think that it's unlikely that
you can be certain based on this data
that these are the things that are going
to help or that these are the things
that are even going to correlate with
that correlation isn't necessarily
causation as we know so yeah the climate
change one is interesting well even if
you accept climate change is happening
and you think it's a major urgent issue
the thing that I find very strange is
that as I said in this country we
produce two percent of all Global yeah
CO2 emissions so even if we never burn
never release another molecule of CO2
and atmosphere would make no difference
to climate change right and yet we are
told that we must kill thousands of
pensioners with cold every winter
and now I'm a bad person yes I don't
want to be a bad person I don't want to
be asking the wrong but but it seems
obvious to me that that the solution
doesn't match the problem yeah it
doesn't solve the problem doesn't
address the problem and the solution
that we are being told we must Implement
is hurting a lot of people and will
continue to hurt lots of people yes Net
Zero will kill lots of people yes
there's no question about that that's a
fact
so even if you think climate change is
urgent and a massive problem why are we
being offered a solution that doesn't
solve it and kills lots of people and
why am I a bad person for asking the
question and then you go well like how
do I think about this now
maybe the problem is that we have a top
heavy population with too many old
people and the whole
maybe they're just trying to find
solutions to other problems masked I
don't know I don't you know that's where
my brain goes to I have a perverse mind
and I think maybe there's another
problem here behind the problem and the
solution what we should look at is the
solution and what the solution does and
start questioning is that the point
that's interesting you see I I don't I I
don't think about it that way my
thinking is I think that they they
it's actually the other thing that you
said which is there is and Michael
schellenberger I don't know if you read
this sub stack is very good on this
there is a particular world view that
you described earlier which is humans
are a virus humans are bad humans are
this and that and so it's not just we
must reduce the population which I think
is what you're hinting at I think it's
much more basic than that which is we
must be punished we must punish
ourselves for the terrible harm look at
that I fully support look who started
the Industrial Revolution humans we did
well it's not just humans it's Western
humans right the worst humans the worst
humans we did the Industrial Revolution
who did colonialism who did racism who
did slaver I mean actually everyone did
we'll skip over that but who've done a
racism
obviously you know no one anywhere else
in the world is in anywhere racist we
know that
who who's caused all these great
problems that we're now dealing with
right well let's ignore the fact that
China and India are going to build a
Coal Power Station every two days yeah
well let's look at ourselves Richard
let's look deep into our soul and
realize I'm waiting we have sinned we
have sinned and we must atone and I
think actually quite a lot of it is
coming from that
that's why the ordinary person sort of
buys into it quite often I I think so I
agree with you I think there is a
undoubtedly a religious impulse to this
like it is sin and there must be some
sort of penance that is paid
um again it seems like a a super low
resolution propositions
and it's weirdly it's weirdly racist via
the back door of course because if we're
the it's what it's saying is
well I don't want to get in trouble ah
[ __ ] it white people white Western
people are the only people powerful
enough to hurt this world they're
terrible evil they're the most evil and
therefore they're the best
at being evil it's still a white
supremacism it's but it's like
this is where slab boy Zizek when he
talks about this he gets into trouble
where he's like no I want Native
Americans to be able to be evil I want
them to be able to embrace their
capacity for genocide and torture or
Africans or or whoever the minority
group is because if we own evil if we
colonize evil and make it only our own
thing it's still it can still be a
passive Flex we're the ones who did this
you see all this terrible than we did
this because we were the only whilst you
would whilst you were in alignment with
nature and uh being at one with the
earth a very nice you Noble Savages we
were the ones who did all this damage
it's still a kind of a weird Flex in a
way
um so yeah I don't I don't buy it I just
I just think yeah and it's the whole
white guilt thing
like come on it's racism it's
fundamentally racism you can't
you can't escape that structurally you
can't be racist against wife against
white people whatever but like it's
ethnocentrism we can at least say that
it doesn't it just doesn't make sense
and it's a form of narcissism as well
100 100 yeah yeah it's mirror gazing
it's absolutely mirror gazing
um and it is like all narcissism it's
rooted in a delusional fantasy narrative
that that deviates from reality because
reality is too traumatic reality you
know when people when children develop
narcissist personality disorder is
because they're raised in environments
that are far too traumatic to deal with
so they go for the infantile defense
this is an infantile defense to a
traumatic reality
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash ticket
use our promo code which is also
triggered and get 50 off the initial
purchase sign up for the newsletter
access of easy which tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
and we are a society that Embraces
infantile Behavior we encourage it yeah
now now more than
now more than ever before that's why I
think
there's a fear of adulthood there's a
fear of responsibility and you know to
be fair it's harder than ever before
economically it's harder to be an adult
you know we're not this is the never
before
the then two yeah I see you've bought
the left is [ __ ] man well it's
harder than 200 years ago
200 years ago you'd be sleeping in a
factory your wife would be sleeping in
another part of the factory you know
what I mean
um
can we make comparisons today to 200
years ago
yeah okay you got me there do you see
what I mean I do I'm not trying to catch
you out no no no no but do catch me out
okay because I want to be caught out 200
years ago people were just breathing
like rabbits because they didn't they
were ignorant for me to go ahead and
read we would just poke each other well
forget 200 years ago compare yourself to
your grandparents is your life easier or
harder it's easy it was easier for them
it was more rewarding for them to become
adults for my grandparents I am not
allowed to be a masculator I call him no
but this is great Brazilian Jiu Jitsu of
the mind I thought I thought about this
yesterday because I wondered if this
would come up
from my grandparents let me present let
me present it to you 1930s so
um they had no choice they could only
they had a potential marriage pool of
about 30 people largely they had to be
in the same geographical location my
father my grandfather was a man rewarded
for being a man rewarded for his
masculinity his masculinity wasn't the
bloated hyperbolic cartoonist
masculinity of steroids and neck tattoos
that we have today what made him he was
a skinny little dude but he could uh he
could fix cars he flew planes for the
Navy he did up houses worked with his
hands he was a useful providing man my
grandmother was a woman she was rewarded
for being a woman she had women's
interests she made
um dresses and did hairdressing for
people
they were rewarded by their culture for
being a man for being a woman when they
got married the greater stress of their
marriage was that she was Protestant and
he was Catholic my goodness me could you
imagine the uh the Scandal then they
they went to work and they could afford
to buy a house by the time he was 35 he
had three of his four children and
everyone was on side with him doing that
a young man today so we go back to a
young man today can't be a man can't be
masculine can't chase women chasing
women is a like a sexual assault liking
women well that's heteronormative
but come on on this part of it you're
exaggerating a little bit before tiny
bits it was easier for them to become
adults was my was my premise I I accept
the premise I think you're right in that
we make adulthood harder now and people
will fear it for that reason on the
other hand
and this is the point I always think
about Mike I take my grandmother she's
15 years well when she's
probably about seven there's a mass
famine where she lives because the
government's decided that that's what
needs to happen and millions of people
staff uh she's Ukrainian yeah
The Peasants who happen to have a horse
which makes them cool acts Rich peasants
so the communists come and take their
horse and Deport them to Siberia they
eventually make their way back
and within a few years Nazi Germany
invades
and there's a holocaust happening that
involves a lot of the area millions of
people killed people go off to war and
I'm murdered and whatever my grandmother
I've told the story before she and her
girlfriends the main conversation they
had when the war ended was will we ever
taste real bread again that's how they
lived
um
maybe it was easier for her to to become
an adult but would I trade places
um that's uh that's a slightly different
question is like you're sort of saying
was life easier that yes but given that
you've made that point I would like to
moderate my premise and see there are
more barriers to adulthood now there
would be no barriers to adulthood before
there's also more rewards for the
remaining infantile
yeah there's more rewards yeah there's
more rewards you know what are the
rewards of remaining infantry uh one of
them is you don't have to take
responsibility okay and people will not
look down upon you for doing it this is
one of the things that happens when you
abolish the concept of Shame which is a
very useful concept shame was a way
Society regulated people as long as
people have kids and he wants to bring
back shame he's fully formed fully right
away no but but it's not that I think
I'm one thousand percent agree with you
it's just that society's moved so far in
other direction that people who want
Society to still function are right wing
essentially right but
am I wrong
from where I sit here today it's hard
for me to argue that I don't want to be
sitting here saying this because
politically I'm not right wing but on on
a practical it's like that's a lot of us
are well it's like vote left live right
this is what they always say because
this is what they say about uh middle
class people in this country a lot of
them will vote left but if you look at
how they live their actual life their
right wing yeah you know they take
responsibility they teach their kids to
take a response all of this other [ __ ]
right so my point is about shame is
shame is the society's mechanism of
enforcing a certain set of rules yes
right you take that away you say there
is no there isn't there's no problem
with being massively overweight we must
not shame people for that and
emotionally I agree with that I don't
want to shame anyone I don't want to
make people feel bad about a condition
that they can't deal with right 100 you
don't have to take you don't have to go
to the gym you don't have to manage your
diet these things are difficult they're
unpleasant often right why don't you
just you know be infantile about it go
this is the thing that's happening to me
yeah and Society will go oh poor little
you or poor big you in this case right
and poor sweating heavy breathing you
exactly diabetic you oh it sounds like a
great kids book doesn't exactly so
Society will reward you for that and all
so if you if you want to engage in
victimhood yeah you get currency you can
and more importantly than that on social
media you get power yeah oh you know we
love a bit of power don't we you know
you know I I I I've been you know
someone asked me where I'm really from
I can go and do a tour of all the or TV
studio as I unexplained why instead of
being being mature about it and going
this person's probably trying to
communicate something reasonable let's
find out what that is let's have a
conversation that's what an adult does
yes but infantile behavior is rewarded
you're not going to get on TV screens if
all you say is
you know someone asked me where I'm
really from I went oh I'm actually from
and we had a nice conversation yeah so
you reward that as well okay uh doesn't
mean I I agree with both of you yes
housing crisis big problem uh that that
that creates challenges and particularly
now you know living standards are
probably not going to be getting better
it's going to be a harder time for young
people to find a job and so on so these
things definitely exist but at the end
of the day if we're sitting here talking
about it from the point of your book and
the conversation we're having
there is no other answer is that than
personal responsibility whatever is
going on uh uh I haven't found one
there's no other answer that's
sustainable yeah I think I think I hope
I
I suspect that this I wish there were I
don't wanna even I I'm someone who's
naturally quiet respond I I lean into
responsibility I don't want to take
responsibility myself Tom I don't want
to think about you know we've got this
problem with trigonometry we need to
sort of I've got this problem I I wish
someone take took care of all of that
for me but I haven't found a system that
I've been able to make
make things happen for me yeah maybe
maybe that's what I need to do but I
haven't found it so the only answer I'm
seeing is you go what's working cool
let's do more of that what's not working
yeah let's not do as much of that yeah
and learn and grow over time and make
mistakes and pay for them pay for
mistakes inexpensive ways and learn
right I don't see any other answer do
you no no I don't but um as as you were
talking there it worries me because you
said
well what you just said was a vote left
live right but then
aren't we going to end up so if people
do if so in a population of people who
do that yeah they'll be the majority
will uh vote left and live left and the
appeals to authoritarianism will
continue
you're voting for them but you're
carrying the burden it's like that John
goals yeah I'm not voting for them right
uh but I'm just saying in terms of my
own life that is the things that I have
found to work as for the way I vote uh I
look uh I've I voted lib demon Labor All
My Life at the last election purely
because of brexit and I thought the way
that even though I avoided to remain the
way people uh were treated and the way
that issue was treated was just
completely undemocratic and that's why I
voted for the conservatives because they
were the only party that promised to
implement a decision I didn't vote for
but that's what the people voted for and
that's why right so and has that made a
big difference I mean probably not right
the the conservative party isn't the
party of personal responsibility either
okay so to take just a slightly
different attack yeah on that
I'm just wondering that now if being
reasonable
um is reaching its limits like you're
very reasonable you're very reasonable
maybe it's the time to be unreasonable
if your enemies are not reasonable if
your enemies are not listening to you
should you continue to be reasonable
you've got a very balanced quite a kind
approach who are my enemies though who
are your enemies I don't I don't think I
have enemies I think I have people that
I disagree with about the way we should
structure Society but they're not my
enemies I don't think I think I think uh
to a large extent the Chinese Communist
party and the Russian dictatorship
they're my enemies right what what about
people who affect uh your child's future
what about people who are going to
promote transgenderism and it's my job
to protect them from that okay you
wouldn't consider those people your
enemies no
no I don't think it's a healthy way to
do that they're not my enemies uh and
also the problem is as well I I I'm I
can buy into the warrior mindset in that
in that thing yeah except we're not in a
physical War like if you said to me
there are some people out there who are
going to trans your kid and we need to
get the three of us get some Shields and
swords and go out and deal with them and
if we do that the problem will stop yeah
sign me the [ __ ] up right but that isn't
the way the situation is me and you and
Francis putting on some swords and
shields isn't going to solve that
problem right that problem would get
solved in here it gets solved by
bringing people to explain Ollie London
who was in your chair a week ago talking
about how he spent a quarter of a
million dollars on surgery to be Korean
yeah guess what I found out he wasn't
Korean
right that's potentially how you solve
it you talk you explain you persuade
okay now is someone who has a very
different view of me to me am I enemy I
don't think that's a useful way if I
thought that was a useful way of looking
at it I would look at it that way I have
no problem with fighting for things I
believe in but I don't think that's the
most effective way of achieving the
outcomes that I want to achieve
interesting I'd need to think about that
that maybe I've been drinking too much
of the wrong Kool-Aid
um I see some some of the the positions
adopted especially where they are
deliberate outright attacks against for
example the family unit or the sexual
and towards the sexualization of
children
um
I view that may maybe I'm becoming a
little more polarized a little more
Extreme as enemies and perhaps you're
right I shouldn't it should and even if
they are perhaps the weapon to deal with
that is still reason debate no matter
whether I see them as enemies or not I
think most people and and I think it's
important for every single person in
this room every single person who is
watching and listening to this to really
understand this and accept this
most people are not bad people most
people are fundamentally good they just
as we have said before they just don't
think enough about long-term
consequences when it comes to certain
things particularly like transgenderism
they get fed a narrative and they they
believe that narrative and then they
regurgitate that narrative I think the
problem is if we start putting it and
having the mindset of people being
enemies
I don't think we're gonna
I don't the chance of us healing Society
is going to become ever lower as a
result of having that mindset I think
that the the best thing that we can all
do
is try and be in the adults in the room
which is to model good behavior because
even when somebody has a great Point
somebody could have a great point but
the moment they lose their temper the
moment they start indulging in tactics
that the that their aggressor is using
immediately that
their status goes down immediately you
start to
have less empathy for them I think it's
just really important that we try and
moderate our language and our Behavior
as difficult as it is and I'm not saying
it's easy it really because it really
isn't no it's hard it's hard so the
solution would be to be aggressively
reasonable well I I actually think
you're right yeah and this is uh
absolutely but this is interesting to me
because I was talking to someone I don't
want to name them because about some of
this identity stuff and they were saying
well the thing is I don't really want to
say this thing because then I uh then I
I you know then people won't hear it the
same and I actually think one of the
refreshing thing one of the reasons
people do watch trigonometry or watch
you or whatever is we try to say things
as they are without going past that and
embellishing them too much okay do you
know what I mean and so I I agree with
you for example that the idea that why
people are uniquely evil and inherently
bad is racist right but I also don't
think that we live in a society in which
is like you know why people are the most
oppressed people ever no it's not what
she didn't say no she didn't say but
there are some people who think that way
yeah and if you say that if you made it
a priority that would be a mistake yeah
it's not a priority exactly so the thing
needs to be identified and described
accurately yeah without going overboard
and without being uh unreasonable about
it in that way so I think being
determined and being unwilling to
compromise are important on on language
and certain things but I think the enemy
languages is possibly not unless you
you're literally in a physical fight in
which case absolutely you switch the
Warrior on maybe that's uh the
linguistic term of enemies is what is
guiding a swords a path that looks like
it's going to lead towards Civil War
because we're talking about our fellow
I'm talking about a fellow countrymen
and in America it's the same thing it's
that same pathway it's the internal
fight
um and maybe that isn't the way you said
there's something interesting Francis uh
you implied that the end goal was to
heal the rift yeah it's got to be
people aren't saying that don't and
they're not thinking that and they're
not moving that direction so that would
be another element of it it would be say
reasonable and also have that as an
objective which is we're actually trying
to heal I think it's very absolutely
stated
um in absolute terms and you know I've
been reading a lot of Tom's Soul lately
and this is one of the things you get is
you kind of get there's no Solutions
only trade-offs so I think what we're
talking about is not to heal Society
because I don't think that's possible
people will always disagree
temperamentally genetically they have
predispositions that make them different
it's about the way we have the
conversation about our disagreements
right and does that does it have to
descend into personal animosity at every
opportunity and we're all I am is guilty
of that as anybody you know trolling
someone online or calling sadiqana a
tyrannical dwarf which he is you know
but but still right it's it's the tone
of the conversation I think rather than
you're never going to heal Society but I
think think if you improve the way we
communicate that in itself would do some
healing I I don't mean to get religious
here but I will nevertheless
um it's when Jesus was nailed to a cross
and he said the words forgive them Lord
for they know not what they do
and I think
if you have that attitude to a lot of
people who you disagree with to a lot of
people there's always a small minority a
malevolent and spiteful
but I think with most people they just
don't consider the long-term
consequences of their actions and I
think if you approach them with
compassion with understanding you might
not change their mind
but you might take a step to some type
of reconciliation here's well I will
agree with you though in addition to
what Francis said and I agree with both
of you actually I think it's what we're
talking here as well is it's about
concept creep there are some people who
you will meet in a bar
and you need to stay the [ __ ] away from
them yeah right and there are other
people who you could get into some kind
of altercation with if you said the
wrong thing and the wrong you bumped
their elbow as they're bringing the
point over and I think it's learning to
tell the difference and I think what
social media has done is it's made
everyone an avatar for the guy you need
to stay away from right like that's why
I think you use a term like enemy
because there's a small minority of
people who are absolutely evil and are
up to no good and they're deliberate
about it yes but I think they are a very
small minority who need to be dealt with
but they I think the way to deal with
them is to persuade everybody else that
they are unreasonable and we are the
reasonable majority
so and you can only really do that by
more reasoned debate that's it there's
nothing else than that I think so yeah
unless you've got something up your
sleeve yeah I really don't know I've got
nothing there's nothing there and also
you know
I mean again it's kind of like but but
be that change that you want to
want to see a world that is descending
into chaos and disorder and people being
dysregulated and not taking
responsibility then be that person who
does take responsibility be that person
who is in control not that we're always
in control of our emotions because we're
not because we're humans but doing their
best to control their emotions to be
reasonable to be that adult in the room
to be that person who is a Counterpoint
to that behavior and say no if you think
about the best teachers that you've ever
had in your education they weren't the
ones who ranted and raped they weren't
the ones who you know who went the other
way and just indulge you and let this
classroom descend into chaos they're the
ones who came in who set an example
who every day did their best and you
remember them because they set an
example not the two other Polar
Opposites and that's I think what we all
need to be and certainly what I'm trying
to be I may not always get there a lot
of the time I will fall and I have my
own demons that we all do but I think
that's
the best way to be to try and be that
person to Aspire to that
it's interesting a lot of that
it comes back to uh philosophy which is
the the Greek you know Greek philosophy
you know trying to be virtuous trying to
establish whereas virtuous and aiming
upwards rather than allowing yourself to
slide downward interesting I think the
reason that Francis and I are perhaps
quite preachy about it or we might come
across that way is doing what we do if
you think about the history of
trigonometry and you've been you've
dipped in at different points is we
started out
talking about everything that was going
wrong with the world right and we needed
to do that because we needed to
understand what was going on and we had
to talk to a lot of people and so a lot
of our conversations were like you know
Francis but isn't the problem this and
me going well what that was it but now
as as we move further I think
uh perhaps would as the show grows and
more people watch it or whatever we also
feel like
we are we're no longer bystanders right
we're in the game now so to speak what
we do who we invite it sort of it has a
small Ripple it's just a small little
Ripple but but it has that Ripple and we
can't pretend to ourselves that there
isn't that responsibility on us and so
we're really trying to both I think uh
be better people so that we this
opportunity that we have to bring
amazing people like you on and have a
discussion and not let them talk for the
last 20 minutes you know
but we're genuinely trying to to be
constructive as people and as
participants in this world that we live
in yeah and think about less about you
know who is being canceled and who
hasn't been allowed this and that but
actually you know how do we give
opportunities to people how do we create
things how do you know rather than being
two comedians to set up a podcast to
complain about things that needed
addressing yeah what are we creating
exactly right you know so you come from
being problems focused to very much more
solutions focused I think so and and
also as well and this is a lot of work
that I'm doing on myself you know
looking at your own shadow
because it's very easy to look outwards
and point out the flaws in other people
and God this person's like this this
person's like this yeah but what about
you um
what about what you bring to the world
is it all good all those are the the the
element that you have the shadow within
yourself what work are you doing in
order to try and keep that shadow under
as much control as possible
and to deal with it
yeah I suppose it's uh how much do you
charge the therapy session we're racking
up a bill aren't we we spend so much
money on this [ __ ] Studio we can't
afford it yeah
no it it uh it I think I have one of
those faces it might be it might be my
demeanor no it's the fact that we did
that interview with you before were you
interviewed us yeah psychologically said
that no one has seen yet so yeah we feel
able to share I'll recover that I will
replace it no I think um but I like this
because
I care very much about your project I
care about what you're doing for like I
told you from the beginning like this is
this is fantastic and um it's nice to
get in there and just check maybe even
pressure to check like what's what's
this what are we doing here what's this
concept where are we going and to see
that there is there is something there
there's some real thought there like
this project worked some people become
the victims of their own success but if
you're still growing inside of the
project or growing because of the
project that's fantastic isn't it yeah
and but that's the thing it's
it it's so important to grow yeah I
think that's why so many people in the
society and you look around they're
miserable
because they don't grow and that's why
they go oh you know the best days of my
lives were my life was at school and I'm
number one I find that a horrifically
tragic statement and anytime someone
says it I feel deeply sorry for this
because you had a [ __ ] time at school
that's true maybe if I was captain of
the football team and going out with
whatever then maybe it would have been
but but you go well the reason for that
is because at school it was constant
progression yeah you were going you know
and the progression was going up every
year you were going to a new year you
were learning things you were always
moving forward but a lot of people and
they get into adulthood what we discuss
what we perceive to be adulthood they
read they they enter just a period of
stasis yeah where they don't grow where
they don't develop where they don't
improve yes and as a result they slowly
atrophy yeah
and I think that's a very real problem
yes 100 100 without air without external
pressure people do actually we're living
longer and the world is a more civilized
place and they sound like good things
but they bring their own problems with
them as well of course don't they like
as you say stagnation atrophy uh
becoming too comfortable and I think one
of the things that we all need as well
is you need that challenge you need a
bit of a fight a bit of a battle
um at least at the intellectual level
just to keep it fresh yeah because there
must be things that even in the last six
months that you believed to be true or
you held as positions that you've let go
of through chatting to people and
chatting to each other and experiences
that you go through yeah the experience
is actually I think one of the bigger
ones for example I definitely think uh
running trigonometry has made me more
fiscally conservative yeah because you
run a small business in this country how
[ __ ] hard it is running a small
business will do that to you it changes
you every time people ask me about
business advice on my Dunder you will
change as a person and break in ways you
cannot [ __ ] imagine yeah it breaks
you it builds you it's a it's a
psychedelic experience you are a diff if
you can do it if you because most most
people can't they say like 80 of
startups fail it's nonsense 99.99 fail
because people can't break they they
lack the mental flexibility to have the
break and then come through the break
and rebuild doing business from
scratches it's I think it's been the
same for you mate to some extent because
you've worked in public sector jobs most
of your life before becoming a comedian
uh and now you're having to you know be
confronted with you know you do this and
this goes wrong and it's it's on you
yeah absolutely and it's
that's that's the real Challenge and but
that's what I was talking I was doing
therapy actually and I was talking about
this and with my therapist and she was
we were talking about regeneration
and in many ways if you're not
regenerating a part of yourself every
six months and you're not changing every
six months you're going backwards yeah
you've got to you've got to change every
six months I am completely different in
many ways from the person I was six
months ago because I have to because my
life's changed because things have
changed because we're in a new location
where and the things that I have to
implement in my life I've got to change
that I've I've someone who I've always
been very anxious and I'm doing taking a
lot of steps to work with that to
improve that I'm learning to drive as a
40 year old man in January yeah and I've
you know I've avoided it and you know
done it and touched it upon it and not
done it because I found it difficult but
well you've got to change yeah yeah
otherwise would it otherwise you're not
going to improve yeah and ultimately we
talk about kindness but I think one of
the things we never talk about with
kindness
is when we're not kind to ourselves and
I think that's where a lot of depression
actually comes from is because
when you don't do things like you don't
stand up for yourself you don't do
things for yourself that you need even
though you put it to the back of your
mind you know that you've let yourself
down
and you're not being kind to yourself
and I think a lot of it that's where the
malaise the depression comes from
because you're not being kind to
yourself
and it's all of those things
Richard so you are our last interview of
the year that we're recording it may not
go out in that sequence but uh as you
think about the last year what do you
reflect on what are your thoughts uh
what have you been thinking about what
is the new thing for you that you've
discovered or you've kind of identified
or you wanted to say
just a cough in our faces just a bit of
coverage yeah it's coming back nice no
it's now the flow mate yeah
the uh the thing that's been um well
I've never I never do this whole like
new year new new meeting but the way
2022 was gone especially as I'm leading
up to the end of the year it's like wow
really a lot of old chapters in my life
have closed
um I've found that as I've become more
fixated in my own life I'm more rooted
in what I do want what I do want to
create the people I want to have around
me
automatically and spontaneously
different situations that were there
different people that have been hanging
around that shouldn't have been they've
dropped off in my experience of their
own volition I haven't said to them you
know I've moved on it's time to go away
maybe I'm giving them a different energy
or a different vibe they just go on
their own way
and one of the things that I'm thinking
about a lot moving into 2023 is just to
get very very focused on what I do want
what I do
I do in life and I think
politically philosophically this country
us as a culture we we all have to do
that now because I can see things moving
potentially in a very dark Direction
where there's going to be a lot more
authoritarianism I don't think anybody
really wants it who's thought it through
in order to resist that we must have a
strong sense of what it is we do want in
our lives and we have to move toward it
in a way that is uh courageous and with
humility with flexibility and that's
what I'm going to be doing personally in
2020 23 is just uh focusing on that as
much so when are you going to find a
wife and have some kids relative I knew
he would
listen fundamentally heart is Russia yes
Babushka want to know you must have
family yes otherwise you're not real men
not real men
no I I I'm sure I will eventually
this year
if I could go to Venezuela that's when
when they let me into Venezuela that's
when I will find there um
also very good if you want to lose
weight Venezuela
as I said one of our absolute favorites
uh thanks so much for coming back we'll
do a couple of questions from our
supporters that only they will get to
see the answer on two on locals do we do
the last question
one thing we're not talking about that
we really should be good Lord everything
that we've been talking about today the
uh the power of
uh simple reasoned good faith debate I
think that's that's uh that's powerful
more than social activism more than
aggressively you know pushing people in
different directions opening up the
conversation good philosophy embracing
the Socratic method here in the other
side and then
building our ideas together fantastic if
people want to get your book where's the
best place to do that uh Jeff bezos's
slave house
that's where you can get my buckets I
watch those films
Cult of one it's called maybe you should
knock it knocked out on its head that
could be a new year stop watching that
Jesus Christ there's an image to leave
you with ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls Richard Grant and thank you so
much thank you thank you for watching
and listening we will see you with
another brilliant episode like this one
oral show all of them go out at 7 pm UK
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's always
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys see you on locals guys
are there indications of sociopathy in
the mainstream media and government
[Music]